hello everybody and welcome back to
another python 3 basics tutorial video
in this video we're going to be
discussing how to read from a file
so the syntax is pretty simple again we
have read me and we're going to open
what are we going to open well let's go
ahead and open our example file dot text
what how why do we
what do we want to do with it what are
our intentions and that's going to be r
for read
and then we can go ahead and actually do
dot read and that will actually read the
file into that variable and then we can
do print read me
so we can save and run that
and you can see that our output is
indeed that information
now a lot of times people want to
read into
memory maybe an excel sheet
something with line by line so there's
another way that you can do this and
that's going to be dot instead of read
you can do dot read
lines so instead what's going to happen
is instead of
writing all that as one bit of
information to a variable it's actually
going to save this into a python list
stored under readme so now when we print
readme we can see that actually now what
we have is sample text to save with
newline newline newline and then new bit
of information and that's the end of it
okay so now you can see that it was it's
created a python list
so those are some of the basics to
reading a file
if you are reading an excel sheet there
are better ways to do it you can do read
lines there's a few other things that
you can do especially if you want to get
rid of the new line but for now these
are just the absolute basics so uh
hopefully that was helpful for some of
you guys if you do have any questions
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time